[Applaudissements]
le témoin du jour ce matin sur RMC
l'imam Abdel Ali a tenu des propos au
sujet de la recrudescence des actes
antisémites depuis le 7 octobre dernier
qui ont Quéré une vive polémique il a
notamment remis en question les chiffres
au sujet de l'antisémitisme on va en
parler avec lui il est avec nous ce soir
l'imam abdelalii pour en parler il y a
d'autres extraits qui ont fait
énormément parler Gérard Darman
d'ailleurs a réagi he il y a quelques
instants regardez cet extrait et on en
parle juste après avec lui il est juste
là merci Nicolas merci regardez extrait
il y a 1240 actes qui ont été euh euh
dénombrés par le ministère de
l'Intérieur bah parlons-en de ces actes
antisémite pourquoi on en parle pas à la
télé moi j'aimerais bien bah écoutez bah
où sont ces 1200 et quelques actes
antisémites qu'il y a en France pourquoi
on moi j'aimerais bien qu'on les dévoile
pour que nous puissions être
véritablement solidairirees et sensible
à cette question vous laissez entendre
que que les chiffres les chiffr je dis
pas ils sont faux mais elles sont pas
dévoilées ils sont pas apparents moi
j'uris voulu qu'on dise voilà telle
synagogue a été profanée tel cimetière a
été profané tel individu de confession
juive a été
agressé bon euh aujourd'hui vous avez
fait plus de télé que moi non mais c'est
vrai possible ça va vrai tôt ce matin ça
tout à fait bon ça va bien merci en tout
cas d'être là on va revenir sur ce que
vous avez dit ce matin au micro
d'apoline de malerb c'était sur sur RMC
euh pour pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi vous
n'avez pas marcher contre
l'antisémitisme dimanche
alors on a d'abord toute la composante
musulmane de France n'était pas présente
pour la plupart donc à part une toute
petite minorité ils étaient tous absents
parce que beaucoup d'entre eux pensaient
qu'il y avait une démarche un peu
malsine je dis il croyait il pensait il
supposait qu'il y avait une démarche
malsainne dans lequelle qui consistait à
solidariser la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme avec le soutien avec
Israël ça c'est un premier un premier un
premier motif deuxème raison
euh c'est que dans le parmi les
participants beaucoup notamment
d'extrême droite qui sont des néo des
fascistes des
néonazis marcher pour soi-disant lutter
contre l'antisémitisme alors que c'est
eux les premiers prêcheurs de haine et
les plus grands racistes qu'on peut
avoir en France et donc moi nous
associer avec des gens comme ça
dans une marche et bien ça nous semblait
impensable attendez attention c'est pas
ma position c'est je vous rappelle c'est
ça vous pensez voilà exactement vous
dites voilà je ne fais que reprend
reprendre et et d'être un peu le
porte-parole de toute cette composante
qu'on parle de millions de musulmans en
France qui n'étaient pas présents dans
la marche parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit comment se
fait-il qu' avait pas pas de musulmanans
donc vous avez la réponse il y a pas que
celle-là il y a encore une autre c'est
qu'on aurait aimé plutôt vu les
événements et l'actualité qui était la
plus forte parce que je vous cache pas
que aujourd'hui les musulmans de de
France ne sont pas leur cœur n'est pas
on va dire orienté vers leur peti leur
peties tracasseries quotidienne dans
lequel ils subissent des actes
antimusulmans ou des provocations et
cetera mais leur cœur je vous cache pas
était à Gaza était avec ces populations
civiles qui sont bombardées et avec
lequel ils souhaitaent ils auraient
souhaité un cesser le feu une
réconciliation et justement d'entamer
des démarches de paix on aurait donc
voulu une marche pour la paix pour le
vivre ensemble pour que nous puissions
empêcher l'importation du conflit Israël
ou palestinien en France et que nous
montions les communautés juives contre
les et inversement contre les
communautés musulmanes de France donc on
aurait aimé que cette marche soit contre
les racismes et contre et pour la paix
et pour promouvoir la paix à la fois en
France comme au Proche Orient voilà
c'est pour cela qu'on on s'est dit bon
on est
déçu ce matin vous avez dit que vous
vous avez vous avez parlé des acts
antisémites vous avez dit j'aimerais
qu'on les dévoile où sont ces 1200 actes
antisémites c'est ce qui a créé
également une forte polémique entre
autres sur sur votre interview de ce
matin vous pensez qu'il y a moins d'acte
antisémite que les chiffres qui sont
annoncés par le ministère de l'Intérieur
pas du tout pas du tout c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit ce matin je vous explique moi
quand madame Pauline de Malherbe Apoline
de Malerbe me sort ce chiffre je ne le
connaissais pas je dis pas qu'il n'y
avait pas d'actes antisémite en France
je sais qu'il y avait beaucoup d'actes
antisémite mais quand elle me sort 1240
voire même 1700 après j'ai appris qu'il
a vu encore 1500 et quelques voilà acte
antisémite en France j'ai été estomaqué
choqué d'entendre ce chiffre donc ce que
j'ai demandé ça vous peine ça vous peine
bien sûr que nous sommes apinés et
attristés et nous sommes à 100 100 %
solidaire avec la population et la
composante juif de France qui est
aujourd'hui victime de cet antisémitisme
mais nous pour qu'on puisse argumenter
et faire un travail pédagogique au sein
de notre composante musulmane parce
qu'on parle d'antisémitisme depuis le 7
octobre c'est-à-dire depuis justement
euh les le conflit de Gaza et et donc on
est en supposeant derrière cela qu'il
s'agit d'acte antisémite musulman
perpétrés par des musulmans donc si
c'est le cas nous avons besoin
d'éléments de détails d'explications qui
nous permettrait nous d'agir et de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
faire un travail au sein de notre
composante musulmane pour lutter
ensemble avec l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale contre ce fléo qui
est l'antisémitisme vous avez vu que la
Grande Mosquée de Paris s'est
désolidarisé de vos propos ce matin il y
a le ministre de l'Intérieur aussi qui a
dit ce matin des insinuations très
choquantes ont été tenues par un invité
de RMC je les réprouve totalement je
remercie la Grande Mosquée de Paris pour
les éclaircissements donnés et pour
s'être inscrit en faux dans la
minimisation des actes antisémites qui
touchent la France est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce soir vous faites votre m à coule pas
mais je l'ai fait tout à l'heure sur une
chaîne d'info qui est la plus importante
de France que vous connaissez c'est BFM
TV oui mais c'est vous serez plus écouté
ici oui et bien tant mieux beaucoup et
bien tant mieux que je puisse encore une
fois une seconde fois pouvoir autant
autant on m'a on a rabâé ses propos dans
lequel je reconnais je reconnais
peut-être une erreur de communication
mais moi mon histoire je parle de l'imam
Abdel Ali Mamoun le français Le Patriote
l'amoureux de la France le républicain
qui a toujours agi pour essayer de
promouvoir unislam de France un islam
qui s' qui s'intègre parfaitement dans
le paysage français paisiblement à côté
de toutes les autres composantes
religieuses ou non religieuse toute
façon en France et qui travaille même
depuis 4 ans à la Grande Mosquée de
Paris pour justement réviser
réformer adapter le discours des imams
pour qu'il ne soi plus imprégné de
violence qu'il ne soit plus imprégné de
d'antisémitisme qui ne soit plus
imprégné de de communautarisme et cetera
nous faisons ce trava travaill au sein
de la Mosquée de Paris pour justement
agir dans ce sens-là alors après
m'accuser de d'avoir des propos ambigus
alors que ma vie tout entière tous mes
actes prouvent le contraire je trouve ça
scandaleux et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
à à ce jeune
Amine qui était qui était devant moi et
qui m'ont montré du doigt et m'accusé de
d'avoir un double langage ben votre
dernier acte ne prouve pas le contraire
puisque vous n'avez pas appelé à
manifester et à marcher contre le
racisme oui tout à fait vous navez pas
appelé à marcher contre le racisme non
alors écoutez écoutez je je répète oui
ou non non je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
appelé à marcher l'antisémitisme est-ce
que c'est du racisme pour vous bien sûr
que c'est un grave pourqu vous dites
j'ai des actes et puis j'ai un discours
non vos actes c'est que vous n'avez pas
appelé à marcher contre le racisme
dimanche vous pouvez pas à la fois dire
ça et dire moi je souhaiterais qu'il y
ait une cohésion de la France parce que
en disant ça vous fracturez la société
en deux blocs oui mais écoutez-mi
marcher à côté de Marine Le Pen ou
Zemour qui sont des prêcheurs de ce
matin face à
person March Jine ma est allé marcher
elle elle est pas c'est pas pour ça
qu'elle est c'est pas la grande copine
de Marine Le Pen ou de est-ce vous
trouvez franchement que c'est une
réponse de dire il y a 30 % je sais pas
combien à combien est le rassemblement
national enfin 25 30 % de néonaz vous
trouve débuté votre interview ce matin
je l'ai écouté dans son intégralité
exactement de la même façon que tout à
l'heure face à cyil vous dites NON je
veux pas aller manifester parce que ce
sont des néonazis mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est d'abord c'est pas du tout le
propos de ce jour de cette journée cette
journée c'est une marche contre le
racisme et dans le racisme il y a
l'antisémitisme pas la fois dire
j'appelle et je et je et je voudrais que
ma communauté et toute l'année nous nous
battons et cetera et cetera ce dont je
ne doute pas mais là nous vous aviez une
occasion incroyable vous pense vous
pensez qu'on va régler le problème de
l'antisémitisme avec une marche moi je
travaille tous les jours contre
l'antisémitisme je travaille dans même
dans n dans tous notre mosquées
respectiv on communique des prêches aux
imams journ tous les vendredis qui qui a
eu lieu nous avons travaillé au sein de
notre composante musulmane donc attendez
on peut pas dire que président de la
République qui est pas venu ça voudrait
dire qu'il est qui soutient
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme non non
il y a chacun qui est dans son rôle
est-ce que est-ce que l'évêque de France
où
les de France oui ben écoutez il y avait
tar coubrou qui était présent de la
grande mosquée de Bordeaux il y avait
d'autres musulmans mais c'est vrai que
nous aurions préféré qu'il a une une une
marche qui soit sous l'égide de
promouvoir la paix promouvoir le vivre
ensemble le faire société tout ce qui
pourrait contribuer mais pas et pas de
manière réductrice limité à la lutte
contre l'antisémme et qui je rappelle
excusez-moi qui je vous rappelle je ne
connaissais pas les chiffres je n'avais
pas connaissance à cette à ce momentl
chi monsieur l'imam les chiffres de de
l'antisémitisme en France il date pas du
7 octobre non mais on dit on parle des
chiffres là on parle de 1700 à partir du
7 octobre non à part depuis le début de
l'année selon
géralendez mais à partir de quelle date
du 7 octobre ou depuisbut de l'anné
depuis 7 octobre 1518 voilà c'est ça
depuis le 7 octobre depuis le 7 octobre
et bien moi je n'avais pas connaissance
de ces chiffres là moi ce qui m'a choqué
dans vos propos là tout de suite c'est
que à la fois vous expliquez pourquoi
vous avez pas voulu vous joindre la
manifestation dimanche dernier contre
l'antisémitisme et en même temps vous
dites que vous faites vous avez un gros
travail déjà qui vous occupe beaucoup
dans l'année pour tous les imams qui
professent des propos antisémites dans
la mosquée donc en fait donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a quand même une grosse
partie de la communauté qui antisémite
c'est pas ce que j'ai dit vous avez dit
que c'était un GR travail vous AZ dit
j'ai dit qu'on travaille on est en train
de faire un travail dans une commission
au sein de la composante de la Mosquée
de Paris avec d'autres fédérations
musulmanes pour justement moderniser
adapter le discours religieux pour
éviter justement pour j'ai
pour qui oui pourrait y en avoir
aujourd'hui un imam a été condamné c'est
l'imam de de tl Toulous s'appelle
Mohamed qui a été
condamné justement pour pour avoir cité
une parole prophétique dans lequel il il
y avait une forme d'incitation au au
meurtrre et et à tué des Juifs et cetera
donc ça il a été condamné et nous
l'avons nous aussi condamné sans réserve
ça c'est bien sûr évident mais
globalement les imams de France sont
assez sages mais malheureusement ils ne
fontisamment pas assez de travail de
terrain de travail pédagogique notamment
avec les jeunes comme on a bien vu des
jeunes qui dans le métro euh chantaient
des des des des propos et des même des
insultes et vulgit TER antisémite oui il
peut y avoir un Terrero musulman
antisémite dans lequel nous devons
travailler donc moi demander à Madame
Apoline des Malerbe des détails en
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous vous en
prenez pourquoi vous vous soupçonnez que
moi je je je doute je demande pas ni des
preuves ni je doute je veux des détails
parce que je ne les ai pas c'est c'est
pas c'est pas une honte vous avez dit ce
matin j'ign vous avez dit ce matin
clairement que Hamas c'était une
organisation
terroriste donc ça là V changeer de
sujet vous l'avez dit ce matin oui
comment ça oui change le sujet mais vous
l'avez dit ce matin qu'est-ce que j'ai
dit que clairement que Hamas une
organisation terroriste vu ce matin vous
vous l'avez dit alors ce matin je ne
l'ai pas dit mais toute façon quand on
commet des actes terroristes on est des
terroristes bah oui bien sûr tout à fait
ouais il y a pas pas il y a pas photo
quand on commet des crimes de guerre
quand on commet des atrocité comme a pu
a pu commettre aujourd'hui Hamas et là
c'est un autre sujet c'est du terrorisme
c'est pas pareil alors c'est quoi
justement la différence expliquez-moi
parce que moi je sais pas c'est pas tout
à fait la même alors pour moi un
terroriste c'est quelqu'un qui agit de
guerre et du terrorisme oui attendez
attendez les deux les deux sont les deux
sont atroces les deux sont horrible
atroces sauf que le terrorisme il il est
accompli de manière anarchique par une
milice non officielle alors que quand on
parle de crime de guerre il émane d'une
armée régulière reconnue alors moi la
question je me pose est-ce que Hamas qui
estam le mouvement de la résistance
islamique est-ce que c'est un parti
politique qui a été élu par par sa
population et donc donc don la branche
armée a commis une atrocité que je
condamne à 100 % et donc on appellerait
à ce moment-là pour justement pouvoir
les poursuivre en cours pénal
international parce qu'aujourd'hui un un
chef d'acculpation de terrorisme ça
n'existe pas en droit international
c'est pour ça vous préférez qualifier
oui bien sûr pour qu'on puisse les
poursuivre pour qu'on puisse cond votre
discours est est tout à fait
intelligible et on peut qu' adhérer puis
en même temps il y a des moments où on
se dit mais où va-t-il parce que là par
exemple vous nous parlez de branche armé
branche armé c'est comme vous légit vous
légitimez le ramass en disant c'est une
branche armée donc d'un d'une
organisation dont on pourrait dire
qu'elle est effectivementelle viir les
condamner attendez attendez excusez-moi
madame je vais vous répondre à cette
question aujourd'hui on parle bien de
Hamas en il y a longtemps en 2006 qui a
gagné des élections c'était pas c'était
pas des terroristes au moment où ils ont
été élus c'était bien une un parti
politique qui a fait une campagne
politique pour être élu par les
palestinens de Gaza donc cette
organisation s'est dotée de moyens armés
que j'appelle aujourd'hui la branche
armée et qui je rappelle et je répète
sans aucune réserve et aucune hésitation
et que je condamne à 100 % c'est qu'elle
a commis le 7 octobre des atrocités
inqualifiables que je condamne sans
aucune réserve voilà et qui sont des
actes de terroriste des crimes de guerre
des crimes contre l'humanité en tout cas
c'est des actes de barbarie quand on
quand on mutile des des enfants on coupe
des têtes s'en prend à des civiles c'est
totalement ignoble on revient dans un
instant c'est pour vous merci à tout de
suite on y
va